上次吳恩達說,
很多大學還在教2022年的工作,
這次他講得更直接,
學生每天在用的聊天機器人對學習很糟,
他是Coursera的共同創辦人,
線上課教過800萬人AI,
這是9月24號在史丹福的對談,
那天世界銀行在介紹新一期的世界發展報告,
整本談的都是AI。
我認為這很明顯的事實
就是聊天對學習很糟糕
在大學中
我們所有的學生
實際上是很明顯的
但是厚實的學術研究
也正在展示
學生使用聊天機器
為學習工作
他們的學習成績上升
但他們的最終考試學校
或者長期學習的數據下降
我認為這是很明顯的
我們在大學上學習了很長時間
但其實沒有驚訝
如果一個學生
與談話機計劃
如果談話機計劃做了你的工作
工作就完成了
所以你得到很好的學習成績
但是學習就受不了
所以我覺得
有點疑惑
在某些圈子上
談話機計劃是希望學習的
確實有些方法讓人們可以使用調調器
這些方法對學習有幫助
但事實上,大多數方法
大多數人用調調器的方法
對學習有很大傷害
記住,非常專業的AI
他們很棒地做事
我經常用他們做事
但我們不要騙自己
他們是一個很好的學習工具
無論是專業的教育級別
高級的K-12
甚至是年輕學生
年輕人通常會做到的東西
但我們不要想著
這是能幫助我們學習的
所以這就是現在的情況
而AI在目前的狀態中
尤其是在現在的狀態中
他說的這類研究
有一篇去年登在美國國家科學院的期刊
PNAS
將近一千個高中生練數學
用一般ChatGPT的那組
練習成績高了48%
可是拿掉AI去考試
反而比從來沒用過的人低了17%
另一組用的是加了護欄的AI家教
這個退步大致就不見了
是從一對多到一對一的經驗
所以今天也有很多網絡教育
每個人都在看同樣的視頻
這也有效率
沒有任何錯誤
它是有效率的
但是AI技術
對我來說 現在有更明顯的路線
從一對多的模式
一位教授和一位學生
主持這場的蘇珊艾菲是史丹佛經濟學教授
也是這份報告的學術主持人之一
她當過微軟的首席經濟學家
還是第一位拿到克拉克獎的女性
那個獎頒給40歲以下的經濟學家
第一位被認為僅次於諾貝爾經濟學獎
她說連大學都還在摸索
教授們等於被丟了一句
AI來了
你們自己想辦法
而這些學生的成績更好
But when I heard those results
I was like great
Like liberal arts college is great
Even Stanford could adapt to that
But what about UC Berkeley
You know
What about larger state schools
What about Purdue
Which has been like great
But they've got a lot of students
And then let alone the developing world
文達說Coursera
現在就在幫沒有AI師資的大學開課
接著他講到AI時代人該練什麼本事
從1997年IBM的電腦下贏西洋棋世界冠軍
到後來的Watson跟AlphaGo
每一次大家都以為AI什麼都會了
結果離真正好用都還很遠
證明方法是一個你能夠確認
So it turns out
Programming tends to be
more of a verifiable task
Because you write the code
It either works correctly or it does not
Math
數學
Because you can
因為你可以證明一個理論
So math problems are
所以數學問題
Because you either got the facts right
Or got the facts wrong
但事實上,
在現實生活中,
我們做了很多工作,
需要判斷,
但這並不可證明。
例如,如果我是在寫一塊設計,我應該寫什麼設計?
沒有明確正確或錯的答案,但有些更好,有些更糟糕的答案。
或者如果市民正在決定
他們應該使用哪個市民的協議
或者他們應該在這個國家
與那個國家做協議
沒有一個正確的答案
但有很多更好的
和更糟糕的答案
實際上,以技術的原因
AI的進步速度
更加快於確認任何任何任務
而且更加難以
確認任何任務
的進步速度
技術的原因是
就是一系列的技術
叫做強迫學習
如果你能給予AI一個方法
去確認出口的領域
它可以在那裡運作一段長時間
然後把它們能夠解決
所以AI進步
是比無確認的任務
和無確認的任務更快的
我認為我們可能會犯了一個錯誤
看著AI能做的所有美好的
無確認任務任務
例如研討
解釋實際問題
證明數學理論
這些都非常美麗
非常非常有價值
我並不是說這些
我並不是說這些任務
他說人比 ai 強的地方是腦袋裡那一大堆背景上次跟客戶提到某
個功能對方表情怪怪的你就知道他不想要這些 ai 都不知道
所以他看好教育工作裡能自動化的那部分變便宜以後剩下還得
也靠人做的部分會更值錢
我說:"你寫了所有這些東西嗎?"
What about bullet point five?
Oh, well, that was Claude's idea.
It sounded good.
and you know,
我甚至不想要做,
I just say, oh, cut that.
I just say,
但是我,
所有的語言都對它們看起來像是俄語
但實際上,不,
人類使用這個技術
和這個技術之間的相似性
這些技術可能是你用它
在你專業的領域中
其實我想給你一個提示
我可以
人工智能系統有很多產品
當人類如Susan和我
花了足夠時間
讀到人工智能製作的文章
我們經常會看見某些東西
說是的,那是人工智能製作的
而很多人沒有了解
如果他們沒有讀過
像我們一樣的人工智能
他們會把東西轉移
以為這是很棒的
不知人們真正的經驗
能夠看到這些東西
知道它是人工智能製作的
但是有些人用AI來創造文章
就要考慮一下
在現在的情況下
科技有很多解釋
所以你沒有花太多時間
例如我們在研究這件事
你的內容可能會有很多
你不知道的解釋
沒錯
我還發現
有些學生
沒有英文經驗
他們比較多時間
跟CLAUDE聊天
而不是跟人們聊天
談到政策
溫達給開發中國家的建議裡有一條
是投資培訓
他說美國跟中國雖然領先
差距其實沒那麼大
因為AI出來還沒多久
現在要讓人才跟上
甚至一口氣跳過去
機會比以前大
Boy, that was a waste of time
I should not have bothered to learn that
It just doesn't seem to happen, does it?
Instead, the practical experience of
I think all of us is that
我們花了幾乎所有時間學習
turned out to be a pretty good idea
It turns out at the societal level
because gaining skills has
relatively little short-term return
but a profound long-term return
and human psychology
all of us were not as good as
在長期的計劃中
我認為我就是這樣的
我認為我們都是這樣的
所以實際上
幾乎所有人
幾乎所有企業
幾乎所有國家
都不投資在訓練
相當於會發揮
一個非常重要的
公司級或國籍級的
經濟回報
所以我認為
第一個評價
你學習的重要性
這些都很重要
但是我認為,從非常早期的兒童教育訓練到年輕教育訓練,
我認為,
尤其是在這種改變的環境中,
我們對教育訓練和教育訓練有很大的投資。
因此,在你自己的個人經驗中,
我認為你學習的時間,
聊天機器人可以幫你把作業做完
學會還是得靠你自己花時間
吳文達的建議是多投資自己
他說幾乎沒有人回頭覺得學過的東西是浪費
原影片46分鐘
前面他還講到
對開發中國家來說
開源的模型是別人關不掉的AI
後面他給各國政府的建議是
現在投資AI就像當年美國蓋鐵路
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多